hi i'm kelly i'm a tasty culinary
producer and i
love potatoes i would eat them at every
meal if i could but what i really love
are crispy potatoes i'm talking potato
chips
french fries double fried smashed
potatoes i
love it all crispy potatoes are soft and
pillowy on the inside and
crunchy and golden brown on the outside
it's a dream but we are all busy people
and you might be thinking
i don't have time to make crispy
potatoes at home so i'm going to show
you how to make
five minute 50 minute and five hour
crispy potatoes
let's get started so first up i'm going
to show you how to make five minute
potato chips in the microwave
okay yes i know you could go to the
grocery store and buy a bag of potato
chips in under five minutes
but hear me out first of all we're using
less oil than you would in a traditional
potato chip
two you get to customize it with
whatever flavor you like
and three it's fun so this is a recipe
for one so we're using
one yukon gold potato we're using this
kind because it has a thin
skin and you won't need to peel it
before so the first step is to thinly
slice it and i'm going to be using a
mandolin today so i get nice even slices
you're just going to put your potato on
the prongs put on here and then thinly
slice
i have luckily never chopped a finger
off but katie might have just jinxed me
so we have really beautiful evenly
sliced potatoes all our fingers are
still intact and they're all the same
width so they'll cook evenly
next up i need to dry them potatoes have
a lot of moisture inside so we need to
get all of that moisture off so we can
get super crispy potatoes in the
microwave so we're just going to blot
these dry for like five seconds just to
get all that water off so the oil will
stick so now that these are dry i'm
gonna transfer them to my bowl
first we're gonna do is spray our plate
so now that my plate is sprayed i'm just
gonna add a little bit of oil just to
coat them we don't want a ton
and season it with a little salt and
toss it all together to make sure
every potato is coated in oil now we're
going to take these potatoes and line
them on the plate in a single layer
try to fit as many as you can so you
only have to do one batch
so when i was testing these recipes at
home my boys who are two and four
loved these it was like a special treat
for them
all right so now these are all in a
single layer let's go pop these in the
microwave for four to five minutes
flipping halfway through until they're
cooked through and crispy
so i just flipped the potatoes now i'm
gonna make a little seasoning to
sprinkle on top i'm doing a ranch
inspired
seasoning so i'm gonna do a little bit
of dill some parsley
some garlic powder onion powder and
a little salt i'm just gonna mix that
together so you can customize
the spice blend to whatever you like
ranch is
my life it should be an iv in my arm i
literally put it on everything
my oldest child has taken on my
obsession he eats it with
everything all right they're out of the
microwave they're super crispy now i'm
just going to take some of that
seasoning mix and sprinkle it on top
not only does it taste good but i think
it's pretty i like the speckles of green
just toss those together get them on
both sides
can you guys hear that crunch like this
came from a microwave
and this one is my favorite to me it's
the equivalent of like the fold-over
potato chip
when it's like folded over so it's like
double the crunch you don't
fight over the fold over potato chips
kitty so these look great they're
covered and i'm just gonna plate them
all right so there you have it that's a
whole potato that we cooked in the
microwave and it turned into
a potato chip let's give it a try
that was so crunchy i don't know if you
could hear it but i'm
shocked that that came from the
microwave from the microwave plus the
seasoning on there it tastes like
garlicky and dill and ranch it's just
amazing they're crispy they're golden
brown
and they were easy all right i'm really
loving these but if you have a little
bit more time and you love a crunchy
french fry this next recipe is for you
the classic method for deep frying
french fries can be intimidating and
even messy
so i'm going to show you my secrets on
how to get super crunchy fries
using the oven they're going to be so
crispy people are going to think you
deep fry them so first up is our potato
we're going to keep the skin on in idaho
potato because it gives it a little bit
more texture and idaho
potatoes are more starchy which will
help with the crispiness to keep this
safe i'm first going to cut off
a little base of the potato so then i
have a flat surface to work with when
i'm cutting so we're going to cut these
in about half
inch batons and just go across the other
way
to create about a half inch fry so my
family is a big potato family
really like a big starch family my mom
growing up always made a protein
a vegetable and maybe one or two
starches did she make french fries
no all right so beside me i have a pot
of boiling water
first i'm adding some kosher salt and
that's gonna season the potato from the
inside out so it's really flavorful in
every bite so i'm adding some baking
soda and what that's going to do is
actually create a starchy coating around
the potato
and give it a shaggy edge which is going
to help that crispiness on the outside
when it goes in the oven so now i'm
going to add our potatoes
carefully so the water is hot we're just
par cooking them and what part cooking
is cooking halfway through we're not
gonna
cook it so it's falling apart we still
want it to hold its shape
cover it back up so we're just gonna
cook these for about five to seven
minutes
until they're shaggy on the outside but
still holding their shape these look
great
i'm gonna gently take them out because
we don't want to break them
up and just dry them as you can see some
of these broke that's okay those ones
are actually gonna get extra crispy in
the oven so we're just gonna let these
cool to release some of that moisture so
they get extra crispy in the oven
so these just came out of their salty
water bath they cooked for about five
minutes
you can see they're still holding their
shape but they have like a little bit of
a shaggy edge so now i'm just gonna
drizzle my pan
with olive oil rub it around this is
going to help
not only crisp up the fries but make
sure that they don't stick to the pan so
now i'm just going to line up my fries
in an even layer giving ample room
in between another secret you'll notice
that i don't have any aluminum foil or
parchment down on the pans
and that's because i really want the
heat of the pan to hit the potato and
make it even crispier in the oven
now that i have them all lined up i'm
just going to drizzle with more olive
oil
and don't be afraid to use a lot here
this is what really helps them taste
like they came out of the fryer
and of course season with a little salt
and then just give everything a toss to
make sure they're coated
i'm gonna go bake these in a 425 degree
oven
for about 25 to 30 minutes until they're
golden brown but we
are not stopping there we're going to be
adding a little bit more flavor
all right so our fries are out of the
oven and i want you to listen to this
do you hear how crunchy that is from the
oven so i told you we were going to amp
up the flavor so we're going to add
some freshly grated parmesan a little
more salt
some fresh parsley for color and a
little garlic powder toss it all
together
i mean do you hear that i'm like shocked
i tested this recipe eight times and i'm
still
shocked every time how crispy they get
how are the other eight times
some were sad oh i almost forgot the
pepper most important part
i think the freshly ground pepper pairs
really well with the parmesan cheese so
now i'm just gonna toss it one more time
and plate it up and don't forget all of
that cheesy goodness
on the bottom so these look really great
i can't wait to try them
but i feel like every fry needs a little
bit of ketchup so i'm gonna make a spicy
ketchup and all i'm gonna do is combine
some sriracha with some ketchup
that's it all right we are done it is
now my favorite part it is time to eat
and see if it passes the crunch test
did you hear that crunch they're crispy
on the outside they're soft and pillowy
on the inside
they are delicious now let's try one
with our spicy ketchup
that has a little bit of kick to it i'm
not gonna lie but i think it pairs
really well with the creaminess of the
cheese
the freshness of the herbs it's really
great combo i
love these but if you want to do
something more epic
and deep frying doesn't scare you you
have got to try
these super crispy five hour potato
stacks
this recipe is inspired by poppy cook's
15 hour tick tock potatoes
she thinly slices potatoes confuse them
then compresses them and deep fries them
to create these golden brown potato
stacks they are
so cool she also has a ton of other
great potato recipes on her page so if
you're a potato lover like me
you should definitely go check them out
but if you don't have 15 hours
and you want to make something similar
i'm going to show you how to make a five
hour crispy potato stack so first up
we're going to infuse our duck fat with
some aromatics
we got duck fat we got some smashed
garlic cloves
when you smash them it helps infuse the
flavor a little bit better we got some
rosemary and thyme
and shallots so i'm infusing this duck
fat with aromatics just to take things
to the next level
this smells incredible i can already
smell the garlic starting to caramelize
the herbs are really pungent and even
the shallots they're great all right we
cooked this for about four or five
minutes
take it off the heat and strain it my
duck fat's ready i got my potatoes and
i'm gonna use the mandolin again
to slice them you can see we got these
thin slices again
there's a ton of water on here and we
need to drain that off before we add the
fat so i'm just blotting these potatoes
dry
and i'm going to add another layer
really just to soak up all that and then
i'm just going to build layers as i keep
slicing to make sure they're super dry
all right so our potatoes are dry and
now i'm going to toss it
in that flavored duck fat and season it
with a little salt
and we're gonna just toss it all
together to make sure every potato is
coated
i have a red loaf pan that i've lined on
both sides with parchment paper and i've
sprayed with nonstick spray
and then i'm just gonna line up these
potatoes one layer at a time
until i fill up the entire thing so when
i was first developing and testing this
recipe
to be honest i was a little annoyed at
how long this was gonna take me and then
i tasted the final result
and it was 100 worth the effort
if you have kids or helpers at home you
know you can give them this job it's
really fun for them
10 minutes later i have them all stacked
up in nice layers i'm going to add a
piece of parchment on top
and then here comes the shortening time
so poppy cooks her potatoes and then
compresses them but i'm going to combine
those two steps
to speed up the process so this is a
brick i found in my backyard
i cleaned it and i wrapped it in foil so
it's going to help press down the
potatoes while they cook and speed up
the process
all right so i'm going to put these in a
325 degree oven for about an hour
hour 15 until nice and tender so once
they're cooked i'm going to let them
cool at room temperature for 30 minutes
and then pop them in the freezer for two
hours so my potatoes are chilling in the
freezer
and now i'm making a roasted garlic
aioli to dip my potato stacks in so it
all starts with
some egg yolks some mustard
some lemon juice some salt and some
olive oil
so this is what i like to call cheaters
aioli because normally when you make
aioli you have to thinly stream it into
your egg yolks with this immersion
blender you can put everything in the
cup and just blend it up and it will
emulsify on its own
all right so you can see how thick and
emulsified that is it's beautiful and
that took
no work so the next step is to just add
some of this roasted garlic to the aioli
and all i did was cut off the top of the
garlic put it in some aluminum
foil drizzle with olive oil and bake it
for about an hour
until it's golden brown and soft so it
comes out really nice and easy you can
also squeeze the whole ball but i just
think it's kind of messy so i like to
take them out individually with a knife
so so good what's it better smell than
roasted garlic all right so now all my
garlic cloves are in
so i'm just going to pulse this a few
more times to evenly incorporate it into
the aioli and if at any point you feel
like this is too thick for you you can
just add a few drops of water to loosen
it to your desired consistency
let's go get our potatoes and start
frying okay i just took my potatoes out
of the freezer i've unmolded them and
now i'm gonna cut them so the first step
is to just take off the ends because we
want really clean edges
to get those beautiful stacks you guys
see how the knife just like glides
through
they're so tender okay so then i'm just
gonna cut
three long strips and then i'm gonna cut
this way about one inch and you create
this cute little stack look at all those
layers it's
beautiful and i'm just gonna add one at
a time
can you hear that we're just gonna do
like three or four at a time we don't
want to overcrowd the pan
because they are sticky and they could
stick together so just let them do their
thing
gently tossing to make sure they're not
sticking together
sounds like a really good rainstorm in
the summer or something
all right so these have been in for
about three or four minutes this one
looks perfect
it's golden brown it's beautiful i'm
gonna take it out of the oil drain it on
a paper towel and just season it with a
little salt
i'm just gonna keep frying these up in
batches and then we're going to taste
test
and voila i just want to open this up
and show you guys
these layers let's try it
oh my god i could feel my teeth going
through
all of the layers this tastes like a
fried cloud
just because it is so soft and pillowy
on the inside and then
super crunchy on the outside and maioli
oh my god
so this one was so fun to make if you
have the time i definitely think you
should try it but to be honest i think
my favorite one out of the day is the
50-minute french fry
it was just so crunchy it just literally
tasted
exactly like a french fry it was so good
today i've shown you how to make
five minute potato chips 50 minute
crispy oven fries
and five hour epic crispy potato stacks
if any of you make these recipes make
sure to tag me on instagram because i
would love to see it and remember
there is always time for crispy potatoes
whenever you want
bye oh yes
you